[Music]
Matt Lauer breaks his silence after
being fired from the Today Show for
sexual misconduct allegations at the top
of Thursday's morning show Lauer
released a statement shared by his
former co-anchor Savannah Guthrie and
let me read it to you there are no words
to express my sorrow and regret for the
pain I have caused others by words and
actions to the people I have hurt I am
truly sorry as I am writing this I
realized the depth of the damage and
disappointment I have left behind at
home and at NBC some of what is being
said about me is untrue or
mischaracterized but there is enough
truth in these stories to make me feel
embarrassed and ashamed NBC has been so
good to me after working at today for
over two decades a source at NBC told et
Lauer's termination came after a woman
accused him of inappropriate sexual
behavior throughout 2014 including at
the Winter Olympics in Russia the
journalists and husband finished his
statement writing repairing the damage
will take a lot of time and
soul-searching and I'm committed to
beginning that effort it is now my
full-time job the last two days have
forced me to take a very hard look at my
own troubling flaws it's been humbling
[Music]